[Music]
hey everybody yeah did this move this
looks like it moved yeah because
normally i can't yeah i didn't know that
that doesn't matter here let me move it
over here
[Laughter]
that's all it is now it looks really
weird like it looks like a weird little
dick like come around
like coming down into the frame you know
all about it
coming down
the uh
so we're gonna do um mommy dearest
yes this is a pretty good movie you had
now you
and you didn't realize i don't think
that you realize the extent to the uh
the way this movie has saturated the
cultural no uh zeitgeist no even
nowadays there are people i think and
honestly i think a lot of it um
is not just because it's become sort of
like a camp classic like an
unintentional comedy in a lot of ways
um i kind of feel like
particularly the drag community
have really made this an enduring
because i honestly i don't think there
has been a single season of rupaul's
drag race that didn't have at least one
contestant that did some [ __ ] from this
right yeah it's like it's a big thing
it's a big deal it's a [ __ ] weird
movie
i understand it though you know i mean
[ __ ]
abusive ass mom
[ __ ] yeah and uh she's kind of a
fading star
and she starts adopting children they
only talk about the two that she adopted
but she actually adopted jenny says
later on she adopted two more they're
not in this yeah they didn't even
mention that
so
and this started like back in the 50s
that she started to adopt them so this
was kind of like
celebrities ended up doing this [ __ ]
they still do it adopting a bunch of
children and just kind of they do it for
[ __ ] publicity really
it's just [ __ ] hardcore
looking it's a quite a movie quite a
movie [ __ ] jesus
now this is uh you know this is
according to the to the daughter the
step the the adopted daughter yeah
christina yeah now you know some people
cooperate what she says but yeah i don't
doubt it i do not doubt yeah that's the
thing i kind of feel like a lot of
people her book came out in 1978 which
was a year after her mom joan crawford
jim crawford died
and i think this was kind of i think
there had been one or two previous but
this was kind of the first real
high-profile
celebrity kid tell-all that was kind of
saying you know this golden this goddess
of golden era hollywood was actually not
what she appeared to be and so i think
that christina got a little bit raked
over the coals i don't think the same
thing would happen nowadays because i
think people have a lot more
uh of an understanding of child abuse
and stuff but i think she kind of got
like [ __ ] on a lot and a lot of joan
crawford's friends like people that knew
her came out and said oh that wasn't the
joan i knew and stuff like that i'm like
well that doesn't necessarily
mean is that happening right that
doesn't mean it wasn't happening because
like yeah she might have been like
showing you know she was an actress she
might have been showing like
you know a good face to all these other
people and then getting home and beating
the crap out of her kids yeah you know
from what i can see the the character
that we're given in this movie she's
kind of ocd and um has like a
narcissistic personality disorder
and uh borderline personality disorder
she's she's a [ __ ] trip
and um
does weird [ __ ] like give kids presents
in front of the cameras and everything
and then ask the kid what's your
favorite one and like okay this one okay
well then all the rest of them were
given to the poor
[ __ ] that's the same as giving kids a
present taking it back yeah if you want
to give kids to the poor if you want to
give presents to the poor kids you give
presents to the poor kids yeah don't
give them to your kid and then go away
yeah right
ridiculous you can't really have them
yeah
that's messed up she was doing that kind
of [ __ ] in front of like boyfriends and
stuff and
it's an interesting story
um
and then she gets paranoid she thinks
the little daughter is making fun of her
you know when that's not what it was you
know she was just playing
pretending to be her and stuff you know
just it's just yeah she's like accepting
an award you know kind of a kind of a
depressing movie you know oh it's like
damn you know that [ __ ] girl had to
go through all that [ __ ] you know and i
was mostly [ __ ] it was mostly
[ __ ]
it didn't mean anything it's just that
this [ __ ] was psycho
yeah and the interesting thing um i
haven't read the book this was based on
but from the you know research that i
did now christina crawford herself who i
believe is still alive
um she actually came out after the movie
came out because she was really excited
like her husband at the time was
actually one of the producers on the
film but when she saw the final film she
didn't love it she said that um it was
grotesque
she kind of thought well and see the
thing about this film this film actually
has a fascinating like production
history
initially i think uh what says uh frank
franco zepharelli franco's his first
name right uh the italian director he
was actually supposed to
make this movie at first and actually
ann bancroft was gonna be in the joan
crawford role
and it was actually supposed to be
a very serious
um kind of exploration of the abuse like
the relationship between the mom and the
daughter but as it went through several
iterations of the script and they got a
new director and they got faye dunaway
in there to stuff like that it's almost
kind of it seemed like
faye dunaway's then boyfriend who they
later married
and christina crawford's husband were
both producers on it and it's almost
like they were kind of
trying one of them was kind of like no
we need to make joan worse like more
monstrous and the other one was like no
we need to like make her more human a
little bit and it seems like the movie
almost focused more on joan and her like
glamour and craziness rather than the
actual kid and the abuse i think that
was what christina's criticism mainly
was she's like i thought that they just
she thought that they maybe um
made joan like a little bit too
sympathetic by focusing more on her and
her problems instead of focusing more on
the kid yeah you know what i'm saying
it's not really physical abuse it's like
emotional abuse i mean yeah some of it
is like she does her hair off one time
when she was a little good but we don't
have the full story on that i mean oh
she didn't try to strangle her when she
was older yeah yeah and she did like her
with the wire hanger right that's true
yeah but it but according to this story
that wasn't habitual
it's not like she's getting burnt with
[ __ ] heart with [ __ ] iron aren't
irons and [ __ ] some of the [ __ ] that
tearing people's eyes out like that
happens too and then abuse
some abuse case
you heard that that one yeah they didn't
[ __ ] tore that girl's eyes out he'd
[ __ ] she was only like 16. that was
some weird yeah and i mean like it's you
know it's not like the [ __ ] you know
abuse olympics it's like you know what i
mean it's it's bad like whenever it
happens
but i kind of feel like because
christina was saying that some of the
stuff in the film was exaggerated but
some of it wasn't bad enough like some
of it they pulled back on to make joan
look not as bad
um or at least to give the audience like
an understanding of where she was coming
from she thought everything was dirty
yeah that would make that was something
weird she's like that's not dirty
[ __ ] just
she was losing it because she was losing
her career
dj maniac says i don't remember do they
mention pepsi even once in mommy dearest
yes toward the end of the film yeah she
actually married uh what was his name al
albert alfred steele he was the ceo of
pepsico at the time yeah and uh yeah
they did mary although he's in it for
like two minutes and then like he he's
in like a scene and then he drops dead
but um yeah so so they do kind of say
that and they they have that scene where
she's um
uh at the board like after he dies
and she's they're like well we thought
maybe since uh you know you're a widow
now like you wouldn't want to be on the
board anymore and she's like oh i
absolutely want to be
don't [ __ ] with me fellas she like gets
all [ __ ] up i get to totally
understand why drag queens love this
[ __ ] i mean her
and faye dunaway
she uh has gone a record i have to say i
kind of wish that faye dunaway had a
little bit of a better sense of humor
about
the way that this movie was received i
think they thought when they were making
it that it was this very very serious
movie
but because it was so
over the top and like overwrought it
almost became and this even happened at
the time this came out in 1981
and when they first put the like uh
put the put the posters out for like the
marketing and stuff
it just basically had you know a
portrait like a very old hollywood
portrait of faye dunaway's joan crawford
on there but as soon as they heard
that audiences were going to see it like
rocky horror style like especially like
gay audiences stuff and they were just
like laughing their asses off at it and
thinking it was awesome like and
hilarious
um they switched the marketing to focus
on so now they have like a poster that
says no wire hangers ever and it has
like this like [ __ ] and then it says
the biggest mother of them all and stuff
like that so they started they leaned
into the marketing even at the time once
they learned that that's how people were
uh receiving it and it's like it's kind
of [ __ ] up because there's there's
actually like a couple of really good um
kind of long like examinations of this
movie and like the cultural impact that
it had and it is kind of like [ __ ] up
to think that this is
a movie that's based on a real memoir
about real child abuse
and it's like do you feel kind of like
yucky about laughing about it
but
i mean it's hard not to but i do i love
this movie it's a it's and i'm totally
it's not guilty pleasure or anything
like that i just have i just really
really like this movie i've seen it like
a a bunch of times i saw it on cable
back in the day
so many times and i hadn't seen it for
several years
and tom had never seen it and you didn't
really like know as i said like what
cultural impact this movie had like i
said even people even [ __ ] gen z and
stuff like that you say no wire hangers
everybody knows what that is even if
they haven't seen the movie you know
that you know they might not have seen
the entire movie or even know who joan
crawford was like that she was a real
person but everybody knows that cultural
reference so
you know so you have to say
faye dunaway she was not happy with how
the movie came out or how the movie was
received
and i think that she because she's a
method actor right and she got really
really really into this role
i saw like part of an interview with her
and she said that it took her like two
months to get
back out of
being joan crawford
and the thing about it i think that
people thought
she well she seemed to relate to joan
crawford like the person
and she seemed to think that her and
joan were kind of like similar
personality types
so i think when people started seeing
her as this like over-the-top caricature
of joan i think she kind of got offended
by that
um
and this i mean this it didn't ruin her
career because she still worked
afterward
but you know prior to this coming out
she had like won an oscar for a network
she was in
you know she was in [ __ ] tons of
movies and she was like this big star
and after this yeah she kind of like
did more indie stuff because
nobody really was uh she got like
razzies and all that kind of stuff that
this movie did too
so
they were they were insulted
yeah i guess it's just um
but yeah i think i think the uh
the movie is a downer a bit it is it's i
mean it's a depressing topic
people are gonna
people pay money where people pay money
to see movies in the theater for
escapism most of the time
almost all the time
or
the only reason you would ever want to
go and pay money go see this would be
like kind of a horror movie experience
but this is not a horror movie
it wasn't really marketed as one
although you said they changed the
marketing
to make it a horror movie type
experience that would make more like
they marketed it more like a comedy like
a comedy like an unintentional comedy
yeah okay like a camp kind of that's
what they did you know john waters after
he saw this movie he said this might be
the first movie that i've actually seen
like a woman playing a drag queen yeah
[Laughter]
yeah which of course you have to realize
that that that narrows the target
audience down very
[Laughter]
so
i don't think the movie's that much of a
financial failure it could it wasn't a
financial failure right now it was a
modest financial success it was a
critical failure okay more than anything
i would have i would have kind of
probably marketed it as a horror movie
and honestly i i was i was watching a
couple documentaries about this and some
of the uh some of the comments in on
youtube underneath were like you know uh
you know a lot of people think this is
like an unintentional comedy but it's
like if you grew up in abusive household
then this is absolutely horrible yeah
because
you know the thing about it is that her
character is very over the top i mean
some of the situations are
ridiculous
don't water on you
don't do that
some of the situations are ridiculous
but if you were a little kid and you
were dealing with that that would
absolutely be the most horrifying [ __ ]
ever can you imagine like living with a
mom that just like went [ __ ] bat [ __ ]
on you all the time yeah that well i
know
but yeah which is that that whole thing
where she was like when she got fired
from mgm and she's like then she wakes
the kids up in the middle of the night
and then goes and like cutting down all
their roses
you know what i mean it's like it's
fantastic i [ __ ] love it i love it
yeah i i honestly really like the
overacting of this um
and honestly to me the abuse scenes
while they are over the top and kind of
ridiculous in a way
i also find them very affecting
like the one scene you know where it is
kind of like the first really bad thing
where like you said she's in front of um
jones mirror like playing with her
makeup and like pretending to be her
she's not mocking her really she's just
playing she's just like oh i'd like to
accept this award blah blah you know
she's just like being like her brother
yeah like like a lot of little girls do
and uh her mom just like flips the [ __ ]
out and starts like chopping her hair
off and the scene just goes on and on
and the kid is just like screaming her
[ __ ] head off and it's just at that
point like tom was like i don't think i
could watch this movie
this is a [ __ ] up [ __ ] kid alone
it's like [ __ ]
uh tyler says dunaway gets too much
grief for this movie she was hired to
play a crazy person and holy [ __ ] did
she deliver yeah people like this exist
that's what i'm saying so to me
even though i can see
you know where you know the camp thing
comes from because it absolutely does
have that and you can make it you know
uh make a thing that a lot of the lines
are like very over the top and very
funny but there are people like this in
real life and like i said if you had to
deal with a person like this as a kid
then it would absolutely not be funny to
you in the slightest i can attest right
so that's what i'm saying um you know
and maybe it's like
you know i have a normal mom so it's
just kind of like maybe it's my own
privilege that i didn't have to grow up
so to me it's yeah i can see that it's
funny but i but i can also see that it
absolutely wouldn't be funny if you had
grown up with it with a mom like that
so
in case you don't know if you've never
seen mommy dearest it's funny i was just
watching this girl who did like it was
like an hour an hour and a half like
video
about watching this movie she watches
like a lot of camp type of movies like
showgirls and stuff like unintentional
camp classics
and she said when she watched the movie
first she's young
she didn't know that joan crawford was a
real person that this was like a biopic
and she's like so but so many people
recommended it to her that she went and
watched it and she couldn't believe like
how [ __ ] ridiculous it was and then
she went back and
researched it and she was like holy [ __ ]
this is like a real person and she's
like in some ways that kind of made it
more horrible but in some ways it kind
of made it funnier like when because she
did like this deep dive and like
researched all about joan crawford and
about the background of how this movie
got made and all this other kind of
stuff but yeah so
it's kind of like
yeah here's something weird
i don't know why they didn't mention
this because honestly i had forgotten
all about this in real life
um you know mostly this kind of sticks
the thing about this movie that's very
weird and it's all it's long i had
forgotten how long this movie was almost
three hours
and um just two hours 45 minutes
something like that um it doesn't seem
that long to me i guess because i've
seen it so many times but
it's almost kind of like it doesn't
really have
i don't think it doesn't have a plot
it's just kind of like episodic in the
sense that it's almost kind of like
it's gonna sound [ __ ] up when i say it
um it's like the abuse like greatest
hits you know what i mean like it it is
well yeah and i said it's gonna sound
[ __ ] up when i say it and it sounds
even more [ __ ] up now i said it out
loud but um you know because it
basically just jumps ahead
through years and it doesn't really tell
you like how much time is passing you
just kind of have to like use context
clues i just saw it as like a docudrama
yeah it is kind of like that but like i
said it doesn't really have like a
through line necessarily other than joan
crawford is has issues
um yeah it just shows how those issues
[ __ ] evolved over the years right
staged and
how she
she was kind of woman that was
constantly trying to put herself the
center of everything but which that
worked when she was a teenager when she
was real hot but by the time she's
[ __ ] 50
hollywood's getting rid of her she they
can't make money off her she's too
expensive to hire and she doesn't bring
in money like she used to so they just
start getting rid of her and that's a
huge blow to her ego trying to stay
important
and what she thinks important is you
know um
and in those days they just didn't make
movies where
older female roles were leads in the
movie yeah i mean so there's nothing for
her to do
in that business
and it just shows how
[ __ ] was [ __ ] desperate when her
daughter got hurt had to go to the
hospital and couldn't work at her
at her uh soap opera job she stands in
and plays her role she's supposed to be
a 24 year old girl she's 60 something
years old look at a little hag trying to
play the [ __ ] love interest and [ __ ]
this on a damn
live television show that she couldn't
handle
because she didn't know the back plots
didn't know the back stories because she
hadn't been on it for years i couldn't
remember her lines and
man that would have been mortifying i
had forgotten about that see like when
it got to that idea when it got to that
scene because there's one part like
toward when christina is like an adult
and she kind of goes out on her own she
wants to be an actress as well her mom
absolutely will not help her because
she's basically like hey i made it on my
own so can you i don't want you to be
spoiled or anything like that so
christina is just like working as a
waitress and like you know going on
auditions and she lives in kind of like
a dumpy apartment
but she gets a job on this soap opera
and you know there's a scene where she's
like starts like she's obviously in pain
she had like an ovarian tumor uh so that
had to get removed and so uh and this is
absolutely true so she had to go to the
hospital
and i don't know whose idea it was but
when she's at the in the movie
you know uh joan goes to the hospital to
see her
and the soap operas producer is there
and joan says hey well was it jones it
was joan's idea right like i'll fill in
for her i guess so
i'll fill in for her yeah even though
i'm she was yeah in the movie obviously
faye dunaway was only 40-ish maybe i
think she was 40 when she shot this uh
in real life it was actually even more
mortifying like you said because
joan crawford in real life was 60
something
and the character i think in the movie
she says my character is only supposed
to be 28 years old it's actually worse
than that her character was actually 24
years old at least according to
wikipedia um because i was curious about
it was like did that really happen like
that and apparently it kind of did um
joan crawford was on the show it's
called the secret storm i don't think
they mentioned that in the movie but
that's what the uh soap opera is called
and she was on there for four days
and
i don't think any tapes of the actual
episodes exist but i have seen stills
from it
and it looks
even more horrifying than you could
imagine um it's not not that old ladies
are horrified or inherently horrifying
but it just seemed like
she's trying she's playing a 24 year old
character and she's clearly
in her 60s and a little bit of a rough
looking 60s
so black and white on a [ __ ]
television screen yeah terrible i mean
yeah so it would be hard to light
somebody so i don't know him to look
like a young person you just can't do it
you just have to like spear vaseline on
the lens
like that but it's but see i don't know
like in the movie they made it seem like
it was jones idea
um which kind of leads you to the
question like why would they go along
with that in a million years right
according to the wikipedia thing it
didn't really say it just said joan
filled in for it didn't say whose idea
it was because you could it was a it was
a live show you could write a character
out of a [ __ ] soap opera for 40. i
can't imagine if it was the producer's
idea yeah or even if it was joan's idea
like why would they go along with that
because it's just kind of like
what did they think it would be funny or
did they think it was like a lark or it
would be like a gimmick or i can't
really think of any reason why they
would do that go go watch dark shadows
if that shit's still on netflix dark
shadows doesn't make any sense really
you could [ __ ] jump in anywhere if
you watch [ __ ] 10 10 episodes back to
back there's almost no story progression
you could jump in at any place and
really nothing's happened it's it's it's
drivel well i think that's kind of one
of the things that people liked or that
was one of the things they tried to like
especially those really really long
running soap operas i think they kind of
wanted it to be like be sort of cyclical
so that even if you came in at any point
you wouldn't be too horribly lost you
could like keep up with whatever the the
story was no story progression really
but it might be a little bit of
progression uh in between seasons but
not between episodes yeah
now swifty 1969 i saw a documentary
somewhere maybe youtube that the book
was all made up by christina to make
money see i mean i don't really know um
sounds plausible i mean i wasn't there
now as i mentioned earlier they don't
mention this in the movie
but
uh christina and christopher were not
the only two kids that joan crawford
adopted she actually adopted twin girls
a little bit later on i was looking at
the picture i don't remember what year
it was when she adopted them but it
looked like christina was probably
12 or 13 something like that maybe a
little bit older when she adopted these
other two kids and i don't mention this
in the movie
but i think they probably should have
because
one of the things about you know the
thing with the will at the end where uh
you know basically she's like i didn't
i'm not leaving christina and
christopher anything one of the thing
which is true and the quote that they
had from the will that they said that's
absolutely what her will said so they
didn't make that up
but um
the the other two girls that were
younger
they got i think it was 77 000 each in
the will
so it seemed like even more of a dick
move that she didn't leave the other two
kids anything because she left those two
the two younger girls something so there
might have been something going on now
the two younger girls
as far as i know have come out and said
well you know mom didn't abuse us or it
wasn't like that
like i said that doesn't necessarily
mean it didn't mean that it didn't
happen to that one it might happen to
that one kid and like not the other ones
you know what i mean and there had been
several years
you know i don't remember how many years
it was between the time that she adopted
christine but christina was you know a
little bit older she wasn't like a
little little kid has to do with point
of view too
yeah yeah well all of it would have to
do with the point of view maybe it
happened before the new kids showed up
and they just didn't have the background
or the understanding to know what was
going on that's what i'm saying so it's
i just
i really really hesitate to
question anybody's
story um of horrible abuse like that
because
it's okay
horrible abuse makes you think that
they're locking people up in cages or
torturing or [ __ ] well you know what
i mean eyebrow it's not really horrible
it's just standard emotional abuse
really most of it what they're talking
about pretty standard in terms of the
uh on how bad it can get if you [ __ ]
look into cases you know
um it's it's just
that um it was just kind of standard and
so i i'd say it's very plausible that it
did happen
you know if she was saying [ __ ] that you
couldn't be backed up then
you have to call [ __ ] on it you know
like you know keeping her in the cage or
starving her
you know [ __ ]
beating her on a daily basis black and
blue then you have to have [ __ ]
evidence for that
there's no evidence for that but what
she's her claims are not that outrageous
no not really that's the thing you're
not that outrageous that's why i'm going
to say yeah it probably happened
yeah because a lot of it there was some
physical abuse and i guess apparently
like joan crawford did have a problem
with alcoholism and things like that so
um but i think mostly it was
psychological emotional abuse which like
i said is kind of hard to
prove making her clean things that
weren't dirty [ __ ] uh getting upset
about the coat hangers
uh [ __ ] thinking you know getting
becoming paranoid oh you're making fun
of me you know
well and just like constantly like
degrading her like in the in a way that
you know making her give her presents
away the whole thing
like that whole thing at the beginning
like with the swimming race and like you
know her being bigger she wouldn't let
the little kid win right she's like i'll
always win because i'm bigger than you
and i'm faster than you and life isn't
fair
and stuff like that which is true
so right the the the claims are not real
extraordinary claims yeah just that the
the kid
the kids saw it as mean spirited and
stuck with her so and this is how it was
portrayed in the movie like you know she
was a [ __ ]
this is a [ __ ] you know which i'm gonna
say okay she probably wasn't big like i
said that's not great and and most even
people that were friends with her and
liked her said she was a very i mean she
did come from nothing i mean she was
very very poor
and she kind of made it to the top of
the hollywood heap pretty much through
her own determination and i liked her
quotes about hollywood there's in this
movie that they're i like what she said
about she said [ __ ] hollywood was a
[ __ ] shitty town [ __ ] shitty job
and yeah she said that [ __ ] she kept
her mouth shut on all the damn [ __ ]
uh the dirt that's all that everybody
had on everybody else and all the
scandals that they've been keeping under
wraps and
she doesn't name any names or say what
it is but you know it's [ __ ] sex and
drugs and [ __ ] betrayal and [ __ ] and
it's just like yeah
yeah i mean it's always the same as the
same as it always was and evidently that
goes all the way back to the 20s that
was bad then well tyler says i think
this story is true hollywood is still
[ __ ] up but old hollywood was way
[ __ ] yeah i mean yeah old hollywood
they were like covering up [ __ ]
murders they were doing all kind of
[ __ ] harold flynn and [ __ ] with his
16 year old girls and all the cocaine
and [ __ ] sex rooms so it's like
people get his own arrow flynn had his
own sex slave he bought her yeah from
the parents yeah i mean people talk
about [ __ ] up [ __ ] nowadays but i
think it was way worse she's like 14 or
15 bought a 14 year old girlfriend it
was worse than they were better at
covering it up they didn't find out
about it so like much later yeah
um zach says oh uh tammy mentioned too
not all children in a family get abused
exactly some abusers focus on one child
and i think the reason that
um if you know if this story happened
the way that the book said
i think maybe the reason
of and they kind of hint about this in
the movie too where
she goes after christina because maybe
she sees
christina as a rival a little bit um
which definitely comes into play like
later on once the little girl is like
old enough
to
uh you know when she mixes the drink for
one of uh one of her uncles like one of
joan's boyfriends
and then comes in and like looks at them
kind of like
interested you know what i mean and
after that happens joan's like oh she's
getting old enough to like be
competition for me or something like
that so she sends her off to boarding
school
maniac says yeah dark shadows are super
slow it takes three episodes for a
character to move from one room to
another
in canvas is dark shadows was the
daytime cell proper you can leave them
for years and come back and know what's
going on yeah yeah because i think
people watch them for like you know
comfort sort of reasons like it's just
something you can come on so you know
it's
dark shadows have been good if you can
if you would have turned it into a mini
series not a soap opera but a mini
series yeah where things actually
happened in it things kind of happened
in dark shadows but like i said
that first season could have been
condensed into about four little four
episodes
you know maybe not even that not even
that
it's like let's just make it one movie
and one yeah there we go so you could
take four years of that and turn it into
a three hour movie two and a half hours
yeah zach says i'm really impressed how
people have come around on this movie
and phase performance she was always a
favorite actress of mine and i think her
and the little girl especially are
excellent in this i do too um
yes it's over the top but i don't know
it's just it works for me this is very
early 80s the the the movie
market of the day was very different
back then than it is now people back
then didn't tolerate this kind of [ __ ]
they didn't want to see it
they still want to see that kind of [ __ ]
i mean
it would have been better had you
marketed this to be something kind of
like a long line to exorcist then it
probably would have sold
i think would have been a bigger hit
but just
what they what they what they what they
wanted late 70s early 80s as [ __ ]
basically dumb cop shows
um
they weren't that dumb though either
some you know dirty hairy type [ __ ]
that'd make a lot of money
um
what else
if you could rip off star well you
couldn't rip off star wars the attacks
were ripping off star wars and [ __ ]
couldn't make any money on it
uh star wars
um
it's just
this wasn't gonna be a big hit if you
ask me there's no way to really cut it
cut this it was just not gonna be a big
hit i don't think i mean the result it's
about child abuse well the book was a
massive bestseller which is why they
wanted to make it into a movie like
almost immediately i think that the
rights to this movie were bought even
before the book came out you know what i
mean it's about child abuse and that's
not gonna be a big seller the thing
about it is i kind of feel like even
though i really like this movie but i'm
trying to like think about maybe what
the what the critics were pissed off
about i think maybe one of the things
they're pissed off about is that the
movie couldn't really seem to decide
if it wanted to be about
you know the glamour of joan crawford or
what that glamour
was a mask for i guess
or if they wanted to focus more on the
psychological stuff and focus more on
the kid and the relationship between her
and christina
and
you know did they want to focus more on
the child abuse it seems to me that they
leaned more in the direction of focusing
on joan
and
her persona
and i think that the reason that this
sort of became a camp classic i guess is
because
faye dunaway's portrayal and i'm not
actually and i'm not um you know
criticizing because i actually really
like it but it can come across as
caricature
and so you get the feeling that you
don't ever get to know
joan crawford
it's just because everything is facade
but then in some ways maybe that's the
point is that maybe that's what she was
like i think that's maybe nobody
actually knew what she was really like
because she was so good at maintaining
this facade of perfection
and maybe that's kind of like the point
of the movie i mean that's how i always
kind of took it well look she came from
nothing right she was built up in
hollywood so that's totally artificial
so there wasn't much to her
there's you know
it was just learned behavior
the boyfriend was saying that stop
acting with me the camera's not on and
the camera's not on yeah
actually we were talking about that
scene when that scene was going on when
she has the fight with her lawyer
boyfriend when he breaks up with her
and you know he's yeah you you know the
camera's not here now stop acting and
she says i'm not acting yeah and you
know we were saying to each other you
know does she even know if she's acting
anymore maybe there's nothing more to
her than that or maybe she's acted for
so long
that she thinks that's the real person
that she is which actually i always kind
of found that an interesting aspect of
the character which is why i always kind
of liked this movie you know what i'm
saying well uh what's that who's the guy
that plays hannibal lecter what's this
guy's name again
anthony hopkins anthony hopkins
i saw an interview with anthony hopkins
one time and he this is when when he got
pissed off and and retired
he came back later but you know i'm not
acting anymore
but uh what he said i think is true he
says you cannot be a good actor for very
long and drives you crazy it's not
mentally healthy so you have to take
breaks from this
and i think that's
probably what was up with joan crawford
she made a living
when she was young
and hot as being an actress all she did
was play roles she was rewarded for
playing roles that became her
her personality playing a role and you
get rewarded playing a role and you
manipulate people and you get rewarded
that's that's what she became
she didn't have any real life skills
other than that it's not like she was
working in a shop dealing with the
public it's not like she was in the
kitchen [ __ ] deep frying [ __ ]
oysters and [ __ ] putting them on a plate
and
you know or no real life skills i mean
not that i know i don't know that much
about uh she did like live through the
depression and stuff and apparently she
had like real tough she had like a real
rough childhood yeah uh you know she was
very like uh really poor and i'm not
talking about just like kind of halfway
because she was a kid though yeah when
that was happening yeah so then as an
adult though that's not the life that
she had
okay dude
life that she had was living in luxury
and manipulating people and getting paid
for it that's that's right yeah that's
what that's what an actor it is a
professional liar basically
yeah well and it's not a show it's
interesting too we're very rewarded for
that yeah but like i said that's not you
those are roles that you're giving yeah
okay and it doesn't last very long
especially for women in that era right
you know once you get once you start
pushing 30 40 years old
you're not going to get any roles
anymore and they do kind of go into that
a little bit i mean yes you want an
oscar for mildred pierce
but
you know after that the roles start
drying up she's getting old you know
what i mean and she can't be like this
beautiful starlet as as much as she
tries and they actually show her in the
movie like you know jogging alongside
the [ __ ] car like her uh you know her
housekeeper or whatever is like driving
alongside it's like doing that thing
with her face where she she sleeps with
her face in that [ __ ] sling like it's
presumably to like keep her jowls from
falling or whatever and then she does
that thing at the beginning when she's
like scrubbing and scrubbing and
scrubbing and then like she's putting
boiling water in her face and then
putting like cold witch hazel and [ __ ]
like that on her face like trying to
keep her
skin tight and all this other kind of
stuff like i don't think those
old movie stars like that have normal
lives at all oh absolutely not and i
don't think their minds were very normal
um
now some of those movie stars in the
more recent era you know they said that
you know some of them are are like
normal guys like they say [ __ ] kurt
russell's normal another one that they
say is normal is uh
um harrison ford
but harrison ford was a dude that you
hired to come fix your cabinets really
yeah i mean he had something of a
regular life before he got famous just
i've heard people who interviews with
people who know him
mention about him
and they say that he's just so laid back
and doesn't give a [ __ ]
he's kind of like mr cool guy and the
reason why he got mr cool guy and why he
did well is because he could deliver on
camera but he didn't care
he didn't care about hollywood and that
for some reason that he
that made him
that moved him up i guess it made him
more of an alpha
and he said he was very lazy
you know like he could have been a
director but he was just too lazy he
didn't care
i mean direct and does sound like a lot
of women yeah
well they just said he just kidding yeah
well you know it's not that kind of a
movie kid just he didn't really take any
of it seriously but he just did a good
job so i guess yeah he never felt like
he had anything to lose because he was
just having fun and didn't really care
well that's maybe the best way to
approach it i mean it kind of depends on
the personality i kind of feel like what
happened it's really weird too and
especially because this has become this
movie has become such a touch touchstone
like for particularly the drag community
i kind of feel like it's weird because
it's almost like
the actual like joan crawford the actual
person and faye dunaway the actress have
almost become like intertwined to a
point where they can't really pull them
apart anymore because faye dunaway like
i said
she was in this movie and she was you
know pretty adamant like after
you know afterward like after it was
received the way it was she was like she
always like regretted doing that movie
and
she you know she's a method actor like i
said so she got so into the role
that
it took her like a long time to get out
of it i mean you can't
you really can't accuse her of
half-assing it she threw every [ __ ]
thing into this movie i think that was
was it about her that i read this quote
where it's like she wasn't just chewing
the scenery but she walked in started at
the corner
and chewed up the chewed up the scenery
uh everything like actors and all or
something like that there was like a
really funny quote about it like when it
came out
but
i mean she committed to this [ __ ] so
much so that like the whole no wire
hanger scene where she's like throwing
this oh what happens it's like throwing
they're like she lost her voice for a
long time like she [ __ ] up her vocal
cords and all this other kind of crap
and the one scene where she was
strangling christina
like when they have that big [ __ ]
fight in the living room
um she almost like really did strangle
her she got like super into it they had
you know the crew had to kind of like
pull her off because she had gotten so
into the [ __ ] [ __ ] and honestly
that's what everybody loves the no wire
hanger scene which is great um and also
i love the chopping off the roses and
the tina bring me the axe scene that's
also great but honestly i really like
that confrontation at the end where that
woman from red book is there like doing
a puff piece on her and then christina's
home and says you know her mom says
something like she got expelled from
school and she's like no i didn't which
she actually didn't
and then she's like wow how dare you
embarrass me in front of the thing and
then then they have this like [ __ ]
screeching cat fight and she's like why
can't you
show me the respect that you went you
know what she just like goes off on this
big like [ __ ] thing and then
christine is like because i'm not one of
your fans and then they just have this
big [ __ ] i [ __ ] love that it's
just so overwrought
and i love it i was it's funny because
another review of this that i was
looking at like somebody mentioned in
the comments they said you know
maybe to american audiences this type of
acting seems very like over the top or
overwrought but like in central and
south america that's just normal yeah
so it's like you know so that's what i
mean so they said it's like a telenovela
it's a you know so these like we didn't
really see it as as campy or funny or
anything like that at all it's just it's
everything's very emotionally heightened
no it's in [ __ ] brazil girls acted
like that that's what i'm saying and so
it's so a lot of i just thought it would
kill you
[Laughter]
i got on video yeah
knives and [ __ ] threatening some dude
because i'm gonna chop it off
yeah i mean it's yeah it's part of its
cultural context too like i said like to
us if i see you looking at her again i
kill you yeah that's you know i mean to
us like to
largely to like american and british
audiences too in a way where we we tend
to prefer acting that's a little more at
least nowadays that's a little more
naturalistic
um i don't know i kind of feel like i
think zach was just saying that um
yeah he said something i noticed with
joan crawford's movies is early in her
career she gave subtle and kind of
modern performances and as she got older
her acting got crazy more crazy and
theatrical
yeah and that's which is weird because
that's kind of like the opposite to how
the rest of hollywood was going because
like i feel like everything started out
very stagey and theatrical and over the
top and then you know
starting in like probably the 1960s
everything went into like a more like
low-key naturalistic
you know not so acting you know what i'm
saying sorry what tyler says harrison
ford is a failed actor turned to
mediocre carpenter turned to massively
successful
just it just goes to show how how life
can do some crazy [ __ ]
because he didn't care
it might be
he didn't feel like he had anything to
lose
i mean i can see
i mean i you know you've done acting and
i haven't i don't think early though
yeah i don't think i'd be any good at it
i'm just really not good at like
pretending to be somebody else some
people are good at that but i wouldn't
want to do it for a living
yeah i can see how i mean depending on
your personality type i can see how that
would like [ __ ] you up after a while
yeah especially if you
throw yourself into roles like faye
dunaway did with this
um you know so you hear stuff about like
christian bale and people like that who
get really into
their roles
and people like that even though they
give amazing performances a lot of the
times i think their mental health
ultimately suffers think about it you're
not you're you're a professional
pretender you can pretend yeah thing you
can do it on stage you understand
blocking and lighting but you but that's
all you can do and you're pretending to
be a person who can really do things
which that's the conundrum i think that
[ __ ] tom cruise got himself in oh i'm
just pretending to be a pilot just
pretending to be a guy who rides a
motorcycle i'm just pretending to be the
[ __ ] i don't really want to do it so
then you know he
scientology [ __ ] pushed him into
[ __ ] actually doing it
although they used him as an
advertisement they profited off him but
he don't give a [ __ ] he's got his own
cult now basically he's basically number
two in scientology i think
that's just him and david miscavige
riding their little motorcycle right
there
they're little bees the little baby
with their little tiny booties it's a sh
it's a short guy it's a short guy club
short guy mafia tammy says whatever
happened to baby jane crawford and davis
were absolutely amazing [ __ ] maybe we
should watch that tonight and talk about
that tomorrow because oh man that's not
anymore
you don't want to
maybe maybe like next month or something
maybe next month you've had enough
you've had enough you've had enough
melodrama yeah
i mean to think about it like i said i
almost feel bad kind of laughing because
yes this is about child abuse and i will
say that
you know like i said some of the scenes
where the little girl is like getting
her hair cut off or like getting beaten
with the wire hanger and she's like
screaming and stuff we're actually like
not funny we're actually like pretty
disturbing but some of the stuff i
actually really liked one of the scenes
that i always remember really liking
growing up
because not because i could relate to it
necessarily but the one where she's
trying to make christina eat that super
rare steak yeah and christina doesn't
want to eat it she's like it's all the
blood it's it's gonna blood comes out
when i push on it and she's like then
don't push on it and i was just it just
like i thought that was like so funny
well because i love really rare steak so
i would have eaten the [ __ ] out of that
but i just love how that was kind of
like the first
sort of like the first gauntlet thrown
down in this like battle of wills
between her and the kid because the kid
was absolutely not gonna eat that
[ __ ] meat and then she kept me so
we'll put the plate in the fridge and
then she kept like giving it back to her
like at every meal until she actually
ended up eating it but she never did end
up eating it though she actually won
that one but uh but yeah so just like
little [ __ ] like that i really like i
really enjoy that as well that uh that
kind of stuff but yeah i mean
seriously i kind of feel like everybody
like i said even if you haven't seen
mommy dearest you've probably seen mommy
dearest or you know some [ __ ] about it
because i feel like even now scenes from
this and memes and stuff are really
really popular
but
i and so that's why i was kind of
shocked that you had never seen it i
should i actually i'm kind of curious to
read the book
now
because
i don't know it's um
as i said christina crawford has said
that some of the stuff in the movie was
like
too grotesque like or over the top but
then some of it wasn't quite as bad and
one thing that i did hear was the whole
thing about christina getting uh
kind of expelled from the school from
the boarding school or actually she
wasn't expelled she was you know pulled
out by her mom
um i heard that that whole thing was
actually worse than what they showed in
the movie but i'm not sure what the
details of it are so i don't know i'm
kind of curious to read the book now i
don't i don't want to say that i think
the book is [ __ ] because i'm sure
it's not like like you said it's not
like she was alleging
that you know my mom cut off my fingers
or anything like that it was it was some
physical abuse but it was mostly just
being a [ __ ] yeah it was mostly just
like emotional manipulation just
emotional terrorism type thing and just
because the two younger kids didn't
experience it just because some of jones
friends and stuff didn't know about it
that doesn't necessarily mean that it
didn't happen i wasn't there so i don't
know
um
but
i don't know it's i kind of feel like
the
one of the things was that
you know at the very end of the movie
like where they're you know after joan
crawford dies in 1977 and her and her
and her christopher at the will reading
the will and it says you know i'm not
giving you [ __ ] anything
and uh you know christopher says he kind
of like smirks and he's like oh well
that's mom like always having the last
word
and then christina says does she like
you know implying oh i'm going to write
the book about it but christina was kind
of bad because she's like you know i had
started writing the book like before
that before my mom died
um and in fact she speculates that
that her mom even though her and her mom
had kind of reconciled
by or she at least as so she thought
before her mom died
um
her mom knew that she was writing a book
about her childhood and that might have
been one of the reasons that she cut her
out of her will um that's speculation on
everyone's part but
as far as i could determine from
listening to christina she's like i
thought that when i was older like
before my mom died i thought we had
reconciled so i was actually very
surprised when i found that i had been
cut out of the will and the two younger
kids weren't so but she's like i had
started working on the book a year a
year and a half prior to
uh the mom dying to joan crawford dying
it's that's at least as far as she says
because the book actually came out
less than a year i think after
joan crawford died
but uh yeah so this movie is actually on
pluto
for free
as i said it's a commitment it's pretty
long i had forgotten that it was like
almost three hours
but
we had a good time we had some we had
some drinks we had some potato chips and
we sat around amazed by some of the [ __ ]
that she did but
i kind of agree with what zach says he's
only zach's in there saying his only
complaint with the movies it was kind of
his his complaint with it is that it's
kind of [ __ ] you see on the damn old
soap opera but it's set in a real
glamorous kind of setting which it is
it's it's set in glamorous settings but
it's just kind of trifling [ __ ] soap
opera [ __ ]
it is the way it's shot it's yeah it's
not very um artistically
framed or shocked that's not what he's
talking about he's saying that
it's just kind of like
the subject matter is just kind of like
the subject matter out of out of a out
of a soap opera kind of
yeah you know what i mean well a
melodrama like is that an
relationships just mom's a [ __ ]
and i mean something zack says earlier
um that i actually kind of agree with
he's like i actually would have liked a
little bit more backstory on joan
crawford's upbringing like to give a
little bit more insight as to why she
was like that
uh which might have been more
interesting like i said it seemed like
russian
yeah i mean the thing about the movie
the only criticism i have of it and this
isn't really a criticism it doesn't
really bother me that much
but
is it that it's not really like i said
it's not really a cohesive
narrative it's just like a series of
uh vignettes essentially and there's
sometimes there's like years in between
and they don't really like because
there's one really weird like toward the
end of the movie like she marries the
pepsi ceo and then there's a scene of
them like setting up their apartment in
new york and he's like hey you're
spending all my [ __ ] money why don't
you like knock it off a little bit
and
so there's that and then like literally
the next scene he's dead
and she's like in black and she's at the
boardroom table so he's in the movie
like for two minutes
so they skip over a lot of stuff early
development isn't going to be
interesting
it might be no it's going to end up
being the early development of the time
probably in her era area
she's going to be a real attractive
young girl in the in the depression
which in where in what you're talking
about there's a is basically a low-level
call girl that's probably what she was
that's probably how she got ahead in
hollywood
that was the scene
so
probably part of the reasons why it's
always you hey you can pull yourself up
by your bootstraps and nothing's fair
but that's because
of what she had to do when she was a kid
to get ahead to stand out amongst the
competition
you know ass
get ahead and ask well and maybe she
probably like resented it so she was
like taking it out on other people of
course of course
no zach said what i what i said about
the movie looking ugly he said that is
what i meant it was just a very boring
movie to look at oh okay yeah that's
that that's what i thought about the
subject matter that was just ugly
looking i thought the subject matter was
kind of boring too in a certain way yeah
i mean it was because it is basically a
movie about gossip about about
inside of a family well i didn't no i
didn't mind that so much um i actually
kind of liked
i don't know it's i kind of liked that
it went through so many eras of
hollywood and you kind of got to follow
this woman
through her career where toward the
beginning she was actually kind of still
at the top of the world i was when did
they start she adopted the kids in the
30s
1935 something like that um so they kind
of start in the 30s and then it goes all
the way up to the 70s
and um you know i have to say i really
did like all of joan crawford's or faye
dunaway's like uh costume changes in
this like all the
all the different like hair and [ __ ]
like that because she always looked like
super super extra you know what i mean
not just the eyebrows but man she had
the hair was all glossy and perfect and
just those big shoulder pads and she
does like spindly
big long spindly heels all the time and
she was all like kind of [ __ ]
i don't know and just like it was just
funny too because it almost kind of got
to the point uh oh you know what i i
discovered a new term today
um that is actually a sub sub genre of
horror
which is about like crazy old ladies
like that like what have whatever
happened to baby jane there's a name for
that
hag exploitation
or psycho bitty
[Laughter]
i was reading an article about this and
i was like psycho bitty i never heard
that term before and i clicked on it and
it was under like
you know gender and horror or something
like that and there's like yeah this is
like the crazy old lady subgenre of
horror otherwise she said exploitation
seth said she liked the book even though
apparently it's [ __ ] and she loves
how campy the movie i don't think it's
[ __ ] i don't think it's like i think
it's probably true
yeah i mean it might be exaggerated but
i don't know the claims are not
outrageous
so it probably was true yeah i mean
we've known people that acted like this
so it's not that crazy i mean i've seen
people like have [ __ ] people
like this that's what i mean
and as i said apparently a lot of people
do because there were a lot of comments
like underneath some videos about this
and said this is absolutely not like
funny because they're like my mom is
like this or my dad was like this or or
i knew people like this or something
like that like people do act like this
maybe it's just funny to see
on the screen like i said if if you
don't
if you're not directly involved it's
histrionic personality disorder and
narcissistic personality disorder
borderline personality disorder those
mixture of those three
i think it's called you know that that's
exactly what that is
yep
lyrido dude says i remember popping in
the vhs tape just to watch the wire
hangers see it as a kid
no wire yeah and um and my belief is is
that [ __ ] crawford
crawford's early development was that of
a [ __ ] call girl that's what that's
that's probably what she was
i mean that's where a lot of those
actresses came from
i kind of feel like this sort of came
across in the movie as well but i guess
because as i said she had kind of fought
her way up from nothing
and
she was she seemed very type a and
everybody that knew her said this too
they said she would get up at like four
o'clock in the morning like i said she
was like jogging doing these big long
[ __ ] skin regimens she was doing so
she expected everyone else to be like to
be like that too
and if they weren't then it wasn't good
enough you know what i mean and she was
like absolutely gonna give you [ __ ]
about that and
you know fine expect excellence but you
can't treat your kids like that that is
not going to end well you've done a lot
better had she lived in this era in the
era where [ __ ]
hormone therapies and [ __ ] plastic
surgery and implants are so much
easier and cheaper to get
she probably would have held herself
together like [ __ ] cher or dolly
parton
which those two would probably turn out
even better today if they were
in their 50s
because the technology's so much better
and i kind of feel like nobody picks on
dolly parton or anybody like that really
for being an old hag well i mean i guess
not dolly parton particularly some
people pick on like madonna and stuff
like that for doing because i kind of
feel like once you get past a certain
age like if you still look good good but
it's like don't try to be a teenager a
teenager like like act your age you
don't have to be like an old hag or
anything i saw some recent photos of
madonna and she doesn't look bad she she
looks okay for her age yeah i don't
really i don't i don't think it's so
much what she looks like who she is it's
how she's trying to come across like
she's still trying to come across like
she's like like an alpha sex symbol like
she's yeah like 25 and it's like
obviously that's not gonna work out no
but you see the same thing with male
rock stars too you see this you know you
see these kind of like old grandpa
bands that are still out there on the
road like with tight pants on like still
thinking and they still
still thinking they're gonna get like
you know panties thrown at him and stuff
like that and i'm just like
your music's good
but those girls are [ __ ] 60 and yeah
big crazy faces yeah
so it's just
but uh
and even dolly held herself together
pretty well but she's fake as [ __ ] but
she was kind there's a certain amount of
kink to that i haven't seen her recently
but uh she looked good up into into her
late 60s she looked still looked pretty
good
camp guy said i saw a picture of madonna
today she looked like kenny rogers after
plastic surgery
i haven't seen her a long time so i
can't speak to that but i saw some
photos that came out they were [ __ ]
mocking her and she's 55 maybe i thought
she was older than older than that maybe
60
she looked pretty good for her age
um
it's just that it's just kind of
inappropriate for her age
the photo shoot was inappropriate
that's what i mean i don't think it's so
much what she looks cause obviously if
you're in your 60s you know no one's
going to look like they're tucked 25.
um
but she as long as you kind of wear
normally if you don't go around like hey
i have this like this tiny little mini
skirt
some of her [ __ ] it's like she's trying
it's like she's transracial now it looks
like she's ch she became a chinese girl
i guess i don't know
she's a blonde chinese woman i don't
know i haven't seen her i haven't seen
her lately um is it because they pulled
all her all her skin back on her face
yeah
and stapled it on the back of her
i have here let me go camp guy says
she's 62 or 62 or 63. yeah i was going
to say she's got to be like considerably
older than me because i i'm almost 50
and she was like
she was older when i was a kid okay you
know what i mean
i'll show you the photographs that i was
looking at
all right dr yeah tyler said i don't
have a problem with how madonna looks
i've just always found her
narcissistic personality overbearing
yeah i think it's more how she comes
across because other actresses and
singers and stuff like that that are
older women don't get the same
it's not a good photo ever that's um man
she's uh had some [ __ ] done with her
lips yeah she's had all kind of [ __ ]
injected in there
i mean for a 60 something year old woman
she doesn't look awful but i mean the
plastic surgery is uh
is not great
yeah
zach says uh kate blanchette and beyonce
are over 50 i think and a lot of guys
are still lusting over them yeah that's
true
i don't know what year that is but she's
looks
it
that's photoshopped well yeah that's
that's obviously very photoshopped
but she you know you she can work with
that no need for me too says madonna
tried too hard to be relevant i feel
yeah that's that's what i mean she has
that trihard energy which i think a lot
of people um oh she's don't like yeah
that's what i mean it's very
narcissistic yeah so i kind of feel like
it's not even so much what she looks
like it's her attitude as well i think
is part of it and it's in um
there's something about
the type of cosmetic surgery she got
she's trying to look like something that
this is not supported by her her
skeletal
features young tombow yeah she's trying
to change the way she looks not enhance
beauty she's trying to change into
something else
so
dj maniac says beyonce is not over 50.
she's younger than me
yeah i was gonna i have no idea how old
beyonce is but yeah kate planchette is i
think maybe uh maybe older maybe 50-ish
i don't i don't know maybe but kate
blanchett still looks uh fantastic i
think
yeah tyler said even when she was young
she was narcissistic yeah and i think
that's probably the that's kind of the
problem that a lot of people have and
like i said it might have been faye
dunaway's or you know well faye dunaway
got a lot of [ __ ] for this movie too
because a lot of people said she was
difficult because she has dolly in her
60s yeah all right that was dolly in her
60s and
who's gonna argue with that i don't know
if you can pick that up no it's all
white it's all white i mean you're going
to [ __ ] up the [ __ ] up the thing the
lighting yeah
there there you go
yeah dj maniac says i doubt beyonce is
over 40 honestly not that i care i think
she's terrible
that somebody said i want to age like
lauren bacall yeah i mean at least like
have some grace about it for christ's
sake i'm not averse to like having
plastic surgery or anything like that
but
one thing one thing that i think a lot
of uh
that a mistake a lot of people make is
that
like you said
actors that tend to look good as they
get older get a little bit of plastic
surgery starting when they're fairly
young and still good looking and they
just get little bitty tweaks every now
and then so it's not a big if you wait
until you get old and baggy and then try
to do it all at once that's going to
look [ __ ] up right and the more you
try to fix it the more [ __ ] up it's
going to look yeah now that's her in her
70s yeah you can see
that that's a lot of work i mean she's
obviously had a lot of work done but
it's still
you know for a woman in her 70s she
looks great yeah yeah
so you know but she just she's just had
a lot of work
little by little over time
zack says uh isabel lupere is hot as
[ __ ] and she's in her 60s yeah that's
true there was always something like
really really sexy about her i always
like really liked her a lot
man now i want to watch the piano
teacher again i haven't seen that in a
long time
yeah tyler says ironically most people
who accept age look better than those
who try to fight it yeah it's yeah it's
true it's true
well the ones that kind of win get the
tweaks they invest the money but they're
not trying to look young they're just
trying to look better
and that's yeah i think yeah i think
that's the big mistake it's like oh i i
got to like 55 and my face is like
sliding off and i gotta fix it you're
right so you know hey doc put your foot
on the back of my head and pull my
[ __ ] it's not gonna work you know i
mean it's it's not gonna look good you
left it too long you left it too long
just do like a little bit right seth
says i plan to age as gracefully as joan
rivers
i haven't seen is joan river still alive
she died oh [ __ ]
that's right yeah i thought i'd heard
that she died like fairly recently all
right so uh so yeah like i said if you
haven't seen mommy dearest go watch that
[ __ ] tell us
did you think it was a horror movie do
you think it's an uh unintentional
comedy i think it's a combination of
both of those things but i just honestly
i i un-ironically love the hell out of
this movie
i wouldn't mind watching it again to be
honest with you but you know what i mean
i can see how it's a little much like
all the kids screaming and everything
because that actually did kind of bother
me um because it gets funny but then
it's like not funny anymore because it
goes on too long and you're like oh wait
this is kind of [ __ ] up and i
shouldn't be laughing at it but you know
there's there's that
but yeah it's on pluto if you want to
watch it like i said it's a commitment
it's pretty long but um you know it's a
lot of fun so
uh what what movie do you want to watch
tonight that we can talk about tomorrow
does anybody have does anybody have any
suggestions
he you don't want to watch any more
exploitation no
[Laughter]
like whatever happened to baby jane i
wouldn't mind doing it eventually
because i actually do that
but um
tonight maybe we'll find something a
little more
fun or light-hearted like i don't know
like a
horror comedy or some [ __ ] up 80s
thing or i don't know we'll find
something to watch to talk about
tomorrow uh but yeah thanks everybody
for
dropping by to talk about mommy dearest
remember no more wire hangers ever and
we will see you guys tomorrow
bye